[Music]
I'll write it moving on news submitted
by double up to cope will you find out
your ex has a new partner oh that's way
to get over somebody's get under
somebody I think you best way to get
over somebody is to [ __ ] somebody oh now
I get it
look somebody new you trying to say
Steve the heard away and that's like a
Nine Inch Nails on ya alright so the
first piece of advice here is let
yourself feel whatever you're feeling
don't beat yourself up for caring still
no matter how long it's been since you
and your ex were together even if you
and your ex dated eons ago and you think
you should be over it the waves of grief
often feel fresh because really they are
you are facing a new part of the
grieving process that you haven't had to
process yet try taking some deep breaths
cry if you need to journal your feelings
or open up to a confidante what you're
doing is honoring how deeply your heart
loved and can love that's weird
that's tight well I thought they would
listen something about like [ __ ] her
friend there might be on the list that's
for that yeah okay because hard people
hurt people
yeah right so if you're hurt really you
want somebody else in that same chip
with you the best thing to do is like
[ __ ] one of your friends or your mom I
was with you or so with you yeah well
you [ __ ] your [ __ ] mom I will [ __ ] a
mom or mom you're in the her mom oh yeah
that's your mom no that's later
oh thanks for the jump in my name I
don't think I will
I don't think I do I'm petty guy I could
[ __ ] somebody's mom yeah I absolutely
have fun like when I was a teacher
seventh grade teacher and the kids were
like [ __ ] I made it my business to
[ __ ] their moms absolutely it was only
two kids that really knew cuz they came
home and they saw me still there it was
like mr. mole that's crazy
did they know they were little shits -
so you're like you did your classmate no
they weren't my classmate I was a
teacher I registered that as your
classmates you grew up and then you're
like I'm what [ __ ] your mom yeah I did -
me too like why are they calling you mr.
Morris I thought it was when I was a
teacher just the ladies listed because
you guys forgot that you were a teacher
oh really
but now I remember you're the lady see
welcome I forgot see me saying it I'm
sorry Steve I wouldn't disrespect you by
calling your letter I would call you a
[ __ ] before I call you later because
you know the [ __ ] was implying that you
just soft not that your actual [ __ ]
can be men yeah so I hear you alright
moving on to the next one or of the male
special oh no the next one says refrain
from acting on those emotions it's only
natural for jealousy and bitterness to
crop up when you see your ex with
someone you acknowledge those feelings
know that they're normal and remember
they will pass if you give them some
time dude somebody is like they google
what do I do if my ex is dating somebody
and this is what pops it's so good that
I don't have the time to write [ __ ] for
the internet like this cuz like I would
tell you like completely the wrong there
top three I think it's the right thing
you out you see what you see your ex
right is you abort right you might
excited oh hey so good to see you is
this hey man there's many men hate to
hear hear
does she still do that one thing she
wants you to [ __ ] on a chest because
that was always your favorite that's not
true no it was like secretary like sick
nos oh [ __ ] oh don't hurt you you aren't
missing everything you're boring that's
what it is
shat on in your scenario net advice but
if I mean I'll try anything once
I would make it uncomfortable for the
guy so I would go in like for the hood
like the grip of hood but like grab his
ass at the same time I don't think you
would make him uncomfortable if you did
all that why does it completely
different handlebar yeah Wow now that I
know that he doesn't like man kisses I
would do gay ticket wait no he would
[ __ ] call your new frame Oh
so you've you thought that bark was
skittish earlier about about gangs right
about [ __ ] if that was the case do you
not think I would have been doing that
[ __ ] this whole time what I know this
man
he would go to any lips his tongue would
be in my mouth now you're up to speed
based on the conversation we had earlier
that I would be able to like get away
has zero insecurity it feels weird yeah
but if you challenge me he'll flip his
perspective on things
this isn't gay because I have my science
hat on he was scared about earlier it
was an actual moment work for a guy
tries to intimately kiss you out of
nowhere yeah that's scary
that's commitment not everyone's
watching always barking to do it cuz
then oh my god
call the [ __ ] cops okay okay oh god I
gotta commit mascara
he's a [ __ ] duck that's what is it
look at gotcha all right well you gotta
[Laughter]
get this [ __ ] [ __ ] is a breaking
this could be prickly yeah answer your
question or I think it was your question
of how would you handle Bart yeah and
then he's like I do get chicken and then
he tries to kiss his ex's new boyfriend
and then he's like oh [ __ ] and they
leave
so here would just start making out with
her new boyfriend I would have to see it
through if I like was their best
situation I would have to see it I think
we just saw that you couldn't hey listen
hey listen obviously he has been a
commitment I will tell you that stop
looking up your ex and their significant
other on social that's a healthy one
yeah you got a delete there bro gotta
live in the present or the future yeah
everything I had to block somebody I
don't have a music talk to your [ __ ]
Talan my friend block Rihanna no I
didn't want them cuz I used to make
playlists and I know they used to listen
to my playlist so I didn't want them
enjoying my new playlist so I blocked
them or a paluszek Spotify everything
I literally witness for us sit down read
download snapchat find them on their
block them over there and then down
delete it again like I put up balls I
put a [ __ ] walls man make sure got me
to get the wall I would have did it I
build that [ __ ] wall man around my
heart
see you will download your exit profile
then delete it then download it again
and delete it again no no that's
repetitive see okay
there's still a credit cards are [ __ ]
for life it's more about that [ __ ]
nobody why am i giving all these [ __ ]
challenge of the blue Dillon I am so
petty though like I'm the type where
like if it was a bad breakup
I would like [ __ ] subscribe you to
like 40 different just mega that's it
just like whole Goods
but here's the thing when you first
start off like the subscription is like
hell tomorrow you get all if you get
like 15 subscriptions for like $30 yes I
will pay $30 to have this [ __ ] shipped
to your house and I would have like some
freaky [ __ ] to like hustling like no
don't put it in the plastic just drop
you can get riled up for her next oh
yeah but it's just inconvenient yeah
do you hear yourself you're giving her
cosmos she's getting all these tips for
her next guy
this signal read Cosmo that's two
lotteries word up and lowrider magazine
I'm not getting anything that she likes
the [ __ ] reading material next one
figure out what excites you now it's
time to tune into what makes you tick so
you can start focusing your energy on
something productive perhaps you can
revisit an old hobby you once enjoyed or
try something new entirely anything that
conjures a sense of excitement meaning
or passion this is the best part is what
the [ __ ] you doing nice when you retire
like this is not get all over the
[ __ ] body the horse brush it every
morning
it was really I don't know if it was in
conjunction with tips home but I was
listen to the scent like [ __ ] then I'd
rather be sad you do the [ __ ] that
they're saying I think it is her tone on
it slamming it on my tongue he's right
it was just constructive criticism TIFF
Wow okay I think that you're reading it
kind of sad look it's like wistful
they're not registering what it is
because of my voice here we go I'm
trying on five you might meet a new dumb
person it's all sad like what idiot like
I wouldn't want to be that let's go next
one come up with your own let it go
ritual throwing stones in the ocean to
release your burden safely bringing an
object that is symbolic of your
relationship cutting imaginary I lost it
I love this I'll buy something yeah yeah
if it sounds way better than you know
what it is it's crazy because initially
when I say at the tone I was like he's
at the time it was a tone but when she
switched it up it really did sound like
like when does something that's heavy
like that you kind of have to give it up
up be like yeah okay come on a rock at
the water to release that frustration I
want to do that now yeah finally a pond
right now I'm like ah you know I don't
really eat those ball by box huh purely
on the survive so you queen mice you
could play within it you silly goose
coping mechanism number one talking to
an air pesticide oh this music sex you
can be beneficial now support therapy
man and I grew up in a family and
neighborhood and just like in the black
community courts the therapist is not
something that you do is not a cure that
means you're crazy
I absolutely you're also putting out
families you're not supposed to do that
[ __ ] but that's that's how the [ __ ]
keeps being closeted and that's how you
never get any different type of results
my keep doing the same transferred from
generation to generation - absolutely
yeah I don't talk about it you just tell
the kids don't sit on your uncle Ricky's
left thank you that's it you guys there
but you never know why so like go to
therapy and those are actually good -
yeah they're all good I wish I wish that
I knew that growing up cuz I was not
again don't be a [ __ ] or whatever but
then yeah in therapy or what you can be
a [ __ ] and then you get out and you're
like they only cost me $60 I don't know
buddy cause I have insurance
[Music]